there are voices big voices at MGM that
want Brad Wright involved in the new
Stargate franchise maybe we just need to
give them a little push welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so as you know if you're a regular site
tracker we've been reporting that MGM
and Amazon have been working towards a
new Stargate franchise this has taken a
long time nearly 12 months from when the
original decision was made to actually
push forward with the franchise to get
into this point now where it's about to
be announced now we on this channel were
the first ones to tell you that Brad
Wright the original co-creator of the
Stargate franchise original
is not going to be involved that actual
people at Amazon didn't really like the
script that he created just before covid
and that they wanted to go in a
different direction they wanted fresh
blood now I actually don't think that
bringing fresh blood into the franchise
is a bad idea we want something new we
want something that suits 2023 but at
the same time we still want Stargate so
I would argue that we need Brad right
involved still and I created a petition
on change.org that petition says we want
Brad Wright involved in some way with
the new Stargate franchise and we got a
thousand names on that petition within
24 hours now Brad Wright has already
commented on this he said look hundreds
or even thousands of names won't help
they could actually be counterproductive
these guys think in millions
but I know something here doesn't
necessarily know he still today has very
strong allies at MGM
Michael Wright is head of MGM plus and
he's also head of
um scripted material for television at
MGM he has been a strong proponent of
Brad Wright and Stargate for years he
has really been the driving force behind
getting Stargate back in our screens and
was one of the main driving forces
behind the almost
MGM Brad Wright Stargate that we got
just before covid-19 hit he has been
talking for months about wanting Brad
Wright involved in the new project
and I can tell you that from a meeting
that happened two to three weeks ago he
still wants Brad Wright involved
apparently there was a conversation
there were several people involved in
this meeting they were just throwing
ideas around about the Stargate
franchise and Michael Wright and a
couple of members of his team brought up
the rings of power problem now the rings
of power problem is basically that there
was a lot of negativity about rings of
power even before the show got made they
made several mistakes very early on and
really a lot of people have decided to
hate this show before it even came out
now as it turned out the show was boring
but that didn't really matter for me a
lot of the people shouting that it was
woke and it was a load of rubbish and it
was this that and the other and it was a
a front to everything Tonkin
had made their minds up before the show
came out whether they were right or
wrong they hadn't seen it when they made
their minds up now Michael right who
isn't a relation to Brad Wright by the
way just in case you wondered
Michael right fees that the Stargate
franchise could suffer from the same
fate that they actually could suffer
from those negative Twitter and YouTube
accounts they're just going to scream
that this is a workload of rubbish
before they even see it and that one way
to avert some of that negativity is to
get Brad Wright involved in some way
that that would at very least get us
hardcore Gators on board and that
actually he could have an important role
in making sure this show still feels
like Stargate
now as we've been telling you on this
channel for a long time we believe that
penguin in a Parker is actually about to
sign on to do the franchise they will do
all of the development work they'll
write many of the scripts and Mark
Fergus actually asked for the Stargate
project sometime after the expanse ended
now these guys the team behind the
expanse and the team that's going to be
behind the new God of War series to me
has a really good history of making good
quality television they have no history
of making anything that's been accused
of being woke so I am confident that
they can do a bloody good job I
personally don't actually think we need
Brad Wright to come on and show him or
direct or even write many episodes even
though I'd love to see him write in at
least a few
but I do think the show desperately does
need him now the executives MGM and
Amazon might think getting him on board
as a token gift to us something just to
keep us quiet now that is no good I
don't want him just as like as a
background executive producer or
something somebody that doesn't have any
actual influence on the show but bring
him on as a consultant bring him on as
something like that as a producer to
work with the production companies that
are going to be involved in this to help
them keep Stargate to still be Stargate
and to inspire them with his own vision
of where Stargate should go mixed in
with the new ideas the new team would
bring I think this actually is our best
shot of having a show that we can really
really get behind and as well that maybe
won't get killed by the negativity
before it even comes out
look at the grief the Quantum Leap got
even though that actually went on to be
a reasonably popular show there was a
lot of negativity out there before it
was ahead look at Star Trek I actually
think that the Star Trek example is
probably the closest to what's happening
with Stargate a lot of people are
incredibly negative about everything
Star Trek that's new Trek they hate it
and one of the main reasons they hated
so much is because of Alex kurtzman they
blame all of their anger at Alex
kurtzman they say he does not have a
clue about Star Trek he very clearly
doesn't understand what it is and he's
just using it to really promote his own
career the changes he's made bringing
him more in line with sort of the Kelvin
timeline in the early Discovery just
show that he has no clue what the fans
actually want we then get Picard season
three and one of the biggest thing that
people celebrated was that new
showrunner Terry mattalis does
understand Star Trek he actually threw
in lots of things for the fans some
people call that fan service like it's a
bad thing but I just say
we're the people that are watching it
why not do a show we actually want to
watch
so Stargate could do it doing the same
thing fine bring in somebody new and
I've already talked about how Mark
Fergus is a big Stargate fan I've also
talked to you about how there was a
couple of preliminary meetings I can't
say that word preliminary meetings I'm
very early on actually before Christmas
when they were negotiating a possible
contract for this
that actually he was asked about what he
would like to do or what he would have
done with Stargate and universe if it
had gone to a third season he went on to
talk about the planet Builders and the
furlings and a bunch of other things for
about 45 minutes he basically wouldn't
shut up and what he did was he proved
that he really knows Stargate
but
having Brad right on your shoulder the
guy that actually co-created all three
of the original shows that we love so
much
helping you to actually keep the show on
track and to keep it in Canon Etc
now that would be pretty amazing so
there's a link in the description to the
petition we need to get this as many
signatures as possible now a couple of
people have pointed out there are a
couple of petitions already regarding
Stargate but they are can we revive
Stargate we bring Stargate back we've
already won that argument it is going to
happen but now before the decision gets
announced we have a small window of
opportunity that if we can make our
voices heard that we want Brad Wright to
be involved that we want them to pick up
the phone and speak to him before this
gets announced
then we can actually get Brad involved
in some way once it gets announced I
think the party's over they won't bring
him on board after that point because it
would look like it was under you know
pressure from us or something but before
it gets announced we have this
opportunity
so get on there sign the petition share
it with your friends explain it to your
friends why they need to sign it and
let's get it at 10 000 you know we did a
thousand in 24 hours
why can't we get 10 20 000. let's get as
many signatures on this thing as we can
and then we'll share it with Amazon and
demand the Brad writers involved in the
new Stargate franchise one way or
another
but guys gender comes and also tell me
what you think is there anything else we
can do is there anything else that we
should be thinking about in order to get
this idea off the ground do you actually
want Brad involved in some way is it you
know showrunner or nothing for you or as
long as he's involved with something
that actually helps is that enough
I'd love to know exactly what you think
please get in the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution each
month that really supports the channel
you don't have to watch it with the
adverts
as always please stay safe sign the
petition and I'll see you next time
foreign